So when they needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new avengers what if trailer video
and breakdown of the marvel livestream that
they just did with the avengers actors they
did a big avengers live stream organized by
the russo brothers with most of the avengers
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos! We're going to be getting
avengers Wandavision episodes later this year
also talk about what's going on with that too
in all the other marvel disney plus shows there's
actually a lot of big stuff and a lot of good news
just starting with the big stuff first if you
don't know what was going on with the avengers
live stream they were trying to get everybody
to come out and vote so they're just trying to
promote that so a bunch of the avengers showed
up including robert downey jr most of them were
clowning on each other the entire time just
because they're all kind of like a family now
one of the other fun name drops that they
made during this though was red hulk just
because there's so many theories about them
doing red hulk during marvel phase four and
all the hints that we've gotten via the
super soldier program i've done a bunch
of videos about that i'll do some more when we
get some more hints from the black widow movie
but they played a big trivia game and robert danny
jr later revealed that he had actually been using
his quote-unquote infinity gauntlet to guess
the answers correctly i i do have the time stone
and there were three questions burning
questions that i needed the answers to
so i i might have played with the multiverse
a little bit well see there was there was 433
i needed the input on a certain upcoming decision
glad you survived the use of those stones robert
what does that mean until we get to the avengers
what if episodes in the black widow movie this
is about as close as we're going to get to iron
man actually coming back in a marvel project i
know there's a lot of questions because robert
downey jr has said a lot about what his plans are
in terms of future marvel movies for the most part
he said that he has no big plans to come back and
do iron man 4 or like a really big marvel movie
but that doesn't include the smaller projects like
the avengers what if series we're going to get the
episodes of that next summer i'll also explain the
schedule for that in a second too because they're
only doing 10 episodes in season 1 and they're
doing one episode for every single mcu film which
is 23 including spider-man far from home the big
report you may have heard more recently though is
about him coming back in the black widow movie
but in a very roundabout way very circuitous
not exactly what people would expect when you hear
robert downey jr might be coming back as iron man
so the black widow movie mostly takes place in
the past after the events of captain america
civil war but before avengers infinity war picks
up that's why black widow's hair is still red it
hasn't become blonde yet so when you see people
reporting that robert downey jr is supposedly
going to show up during the black widow movie
it's actually going to be footage from captain
america civil war that they're reusing or that
they didn't put in captain america civil war
so adding him via deleted scenes so technically
it's him coming back but it's not them filming
new footage of robert downey jr walking around
on set recording new lines you may have also
seen them talking about black panther 2 recently
because they were talking to latesha wright who
played shuri about what their plans are for the
black panther 2 movie now that chadwick boseman
has passed away i've already done a couple videos
about that so i'll link them in the description
a lot of people are now wondering if
that's how they're going to actually
work around chadwick boseman in black panther 2
to include him in the movie without having to go
full leia in rise of skywalker where they use a
lot of the deleted scenes from black panther that
no one has ever seen before and worked them into
new footage to make it appear as if he actually
recorded new dialogue to work within whatever the
story winds up being for black panther 2 now most
everyone is still grieving for him right now so
as you would expect marvel probably isn't going to
say anything about that movie for at least another
year or so originally they were going to go into
pre-production early next year chadwick boseman
himself was hopeful that he was going to gain all
his weight back and just hit another home run but
sort of bringing it back around to avengers what
if the disney plus series the black widow movie
because of all the things that have seemingly gone
wrong during 2022 and how it's completely upended
the hollywood business of movies and television
disney has actually now redoubled their efforts
on digital productions for disney plus disney is
now in the process of completely redesigning
the way that they make movies and television
shows and release them more for disney plus now
they're leaning into disney plus that doesn't
mean that they're going to release black widow on
disney plus they're still planning on releasing it
in theaters in may next year even though it seems
like it didn't need to be delayed quite that much
it just means that a lot of the bigger projects
that you would hope that they do during marvel
phase 4 marvel phase 5 are now sort of being
redesigned for disney plus release so whereas they
think about the movies and the theatrical releases
first like the really big movies now they're more
thinking about disney plus stuff first and also on
the side about the big movies really good example
of that would be a young avengers movie they're
introducing a lot of the young avengers characters
from the comics in the marvel phase 4 disney plus
series like miss marvel you have the she-hulk
character you have the kate bishop hawkeye you
have cassie lang stature there's rumors that
ant-man 3 is going to feature a version of some
young avengers story lines we got the announcement
of king the conqueror he's a big young avengers
villain it just seems like they're all building
up to a young avengers team-up project normally
you would expect marvel to put something that big
with that much build up in a movie theater but
now it sounds like they're thinking more about
putting stuff like that on disney plus so
whether they do young avengers as a series
or they do it as a movie just start thinking more
about disney plus releases for projects like that
now the traditional avengers movies like avengers
5 avengers secret wars the bigger stuff those will
always get theatrical releases first then they'll
go to disney plus in terms of bringing back a
lot of these classic avengers because like black
widow is dead in present day for instance a lot of
them will be coming back for the marvel what if
episodes they haven't completely confirmed what
the entire roster of season 1 episodes is going to
be like i said it's only going to be 10 episodes
most of the episodes that you see featured in
that trailer footage like marvel zombies captain
america the first avenger the black panther
guardians of the galaxy crossover episode
those will all probably be season 1 episodes they
haven't really said how they're going to tackle
a lot of the sequel movies though because they're
doing one episode for every single mcu movie then
for instance bringing back around to iron man
robert downey jr you kind of understand what the
story of iron man one might wind up being like
what if iron man became doctor strange instead
but what is the what if episode for iron man 2
going to be or the what if episode for iron man 3
so you kind of have to treat the what if episodes
as sort of one-offs even though they might be
loosely connected the way the original comic
book that it's all based on is told as in one-off
episodes as if the watcher is telling you this is
a timeline where things played out a different way
than in another episode they moved to a
completely different story so you can all see
how the multiverse is very important to the idea
and the concept of the what if series and why at
least originally they weren't going to drop the
series till after doctor strange two multiverse
of madness the virus has sort of upended all
those plans now we have spider-man three coming
before doctor strange two we have all the news
of doctor strange being in spider-man 3 there is
a lot of multiverse stuff that's still happening
but they had to sort of re-engineer the way all
the different movies connect because the order of
the movies has changed a little it'll all start
with the avengers Wandavision episodes i think
that'll be sort of the explainer for how they're
going to handle the multiverse in the mcu beyond
what we saw during the first dr strange movie in
the way they explained it during avengers end game
elizabeth olsen was also dropping more house of
m easter egg she said that the series is going
to analyze scarlet witch's mental state in the
idea of mental health so obviously everyone's just
kind of expecting her at some point to completely
lose it and that's really where the multiverse
goes crazy but early theory here for how this is
all going to play out is that avengers Wandavision
will sort of upend the multiverse in a crazy way
and they'll be dealing with the consequences of
that in all the mcu movies that come after it
until you get to doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness where doctor strange finally fixes most of
those issues but along the way those quote-unquote
consequences provide for some really interesting
cameo and crossover opportunities like you've been
hearing all the spider-verse rumors for spider-man
3. the only thing that we know for sure is that
jamie foxx's electro from the amazing spider-man
movies in andrew garfield's universe is coming
into spider-man 3 in some way we won't have to
wait that long to find out what's going on
there was an executive from sony that was
recently quoted as saying that they would release
a spider-man 3 preview before the end of the year
so some sort of teaser or a trailer video they're
filming the movie right now tom holland has been
posting from behind the scenes it looks like
he's so tired he's getting ready to pass out
but the beauty of the marvel what if series is
that because it's animated it's a lot easier to
get the actors to come back to play their roles
again especially the ones that have either died
or the ones that said they're never coming back to
new another big marvel movie like robert downey jr
because in each of the episodes you can say this
is a completely separate reality where this is
taking place where events played out differently
in whatever movie it is that they're covering
really one of the bigger changes even
from the multiverse in marvel phase 4
is the idea of them doing more supernatural
characters darker characters like you get into
the blade movie ghostwriter any of the
midnight suns you have the moon night
series there'll be more announcements
about all that stuff pretty soon too
but let me know in the comments below assuming
that scarlet witch blows up the multiverse in a
really crazy way during Wandavision episodes what
do you want them to do with the idea of alternate
reality stories during the what if series in terms
of release date right now they just announced the
november schedule for disney plus Wandavision
is not on that meaning that it's probably going
to drop in december like they originally said it
was there were a lot of rumors about it dropping
a little bit earlier now it just seems like
it's going to be closer to the end of the year
i just did a video for the new mandalorian season
2 trailer of course i'll be doing videos for all
the episodes just like i did during season 1.
as long as you have alerts enabled for that you
should see all those videos when i post them and
then right after the mandalorian season 2 episodes
we'll be rolling into avengers Wandavision
episodes so see 2020 isn't quite so crap
there is some really cool stuff coming up everyone
click here for that brand new mandalorian season
2 trailer video and click here to re-watch the
avengers Wandavision trailer a billion more times
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!